so Michael today you're on the other
side of the camera we said that a lot of
times you'll begin some of your own
documentary interviews with maybe just a
very you know simple more smallpox type
of a question what are the some of the
things that you do when you enter
someone's home or office or world and
you're about to interview them to put
them at ease first thing I do is while
we're setting up we I never asked them
anything that's gonna I would ask them
in the documentary because you only get
one shot you know no one's ever gonna
tell you the same thing they told you
that you're talking in conversation
about a second time we're gonna make it
much shorter and kind of you know I
already told you this so I'm just going
to tell you they already told you this
answer so usually it's talking about
like oh that's a nice flower oh oh I
like your house you know all that kind
of stuff and then when we actually start
to do the interview I do a I call like a
role a role into it 5-10 minutes so I'll
ask them questions like what do you do
for fun Oh what's your job you know all
that kind of stuff if you know even
though I kind of already know all that
information through the pre interviews
with the producers and then it's really
kind of have to judge the person like a
lot of people sometimes they look like
they want to tell you all like I I want
to tell you my story right away
obviously you can't do that when you're
setting up because you know they'll you
walk in the door they'll tell you their
story before you start you know the ten
minutes you have to do to set up or
whatnot so you have to judge whether
they're that person that wants to tell
you their story right away and it's you
know a lot of the interviewees are it's
a cathartic thing so we'll release for
the documentaries i do which are usually
much more personal in terms of what the
actual subjects are talking about or
they're the opposite is you know a
person who I've obviously they somehow
want to tell you their story their on
camera but they don't really want to
tell you their story so usually when
that person it's like the last thing I
asked in case of the adultery one we
have a lot of questions about people's
countries because its people from
different countries so I was
interviewing a woman from Japan and
they're kind of a closer closed society
and I could tell like she didn't really
want to talk about her her for specific
adultery things even though you know we
discussed it before him that we're going
to talk about that so a lot of questions
what's it like in Japan what are the sex
claws like in Japan how do you know
what's your family what's their views on
it and then get to okay so you know
what's kind of what's your story so
let's these are the two types of the
subjects that we encounter lots unless
they're like university professors or
whatever and then you really don't have
to do anything it's just like okay tell
me tell me your specific field what you
know the mitten then they'll give you an
hour lecture on my say lecture I mean
like their class lecture of the specific
thing that they talk about so that's
basically it I'm seeing that Morgan
Spurlock said that like being a
documentary filmmaker a I mean really
have to form that bond of trust with
your quote and quote subject you know
it's like the highest form of trust in
some sense because they're going to
reveal stuff on camera yes uh yeah I
mean it's there's an art to building
trust with subjects especially in my
case you know there's there's two types
of documentaries that is documentary
where you follow the subject around for
years and then there's the type of
documentary which I do a lot of where
you meet you talk to the person on the
phone for 15 minutes and the producers
really kind of do that and then you only
have an hour to really build trust a lot
of ways that I do that is kind of make
the questions more and more personal as
we go along so when we're starting the
documentaries oh hey nice place and oh
what do you do for fun and then Oh
so what's your childhood like you know
ghetto what dreams and goals do you have
you feel like you've accomplished this
and a lot of these questions aren't ever
going to be in the movie but it's really
to get to a non rehearse to answer when
I asked them hey what's your story about
adultery or whatever the documentary is
about do you ever use self-disclosure as
a way because I know therapists will do
that sometimes when they feel the client
is maybe not saying something that's on
my mind and then they use around self
disclosure and then the person was okay
well they've told me something about
them that I guess I should yeah a lot of
rapport I use a lot of self-disclosure a
lot of rapport building um which is
kinda it's a difficult thing especially
for me being a younger man when I'm
interviewing a 60 year old person from
the Middle East so don't necessarily
have a lot in common with them I do a
lot of discovery disclosure and rapport
you know in the kind of initial walking
in stage of the interview of even
setting up of all your health is like oh
yeah oh wait oh I live I live in that
neighborhood you live over there even
though it's it's kind of a superficial
connection at least it's some sort of
connection um yeah and a lot of those is
the subject of the documentary if they
like you there they'll start telling you
stuff and so that's kind of the goal is
to get them to like me which you know it
curves a lot and then sometimes it
doesn't occur and that's why you
interview more people than your that you
need for your documentary how can you
tell when it's not working oh you can
obviously tell it's not what they're on
camera and you and you you know you
interview somebody up so what's your uh
what's your story about committing
adultery since that's kind of a doctor a
half I've been doing they'll say oh yeah
well I met this woman and I liked her
and she was attractive and you know we
committed adultery you know it would be
really short
and sir that's an answer you would give
a stranger it would probably be the way
to say that as opposed to a friend so
you want to become their friend as
quickly as possible and you know i would
definitely there's obviously there's
tons of business books on like how to
build rapport and it's all do you make
so like sell business little law that
works really well with you know the
documentary film interviewing because
you're only going to have that really
short interaction with people and you're
basically never going to see them again
other than you know premiers or whatever
so those are a lot of good places to
kind of find that information and it's
also very I would say the only
difference between that is you know you
want to go very personal with their
personality as opposed to stay on the
topics of the day kind of topics you
know you want to you want to build
rapport through very personal and deep
stories and what you know like I said
what are your goals what's your
childhood like all that kind of stuff
over know the weather today is is great
you know that kind of stuff
you